dr disrespect might be taking legal
action against twitch
an xbox game pass ultimate subscription
is gonna land you x cloud support
and another delay has been announced
this time for destiny 2's newest
expansion
i'm persia and you reach your save state
for thursday july 16th
[Music]
all right it's been over three weeks
since dr disrespect got banned and i've
spent
too much time researching those last few
minutes of his final stream
to find absolutely nothing but thanks to
pc gamer there is one thing we do know
doc might be taking legal action against
twitch dr disrespect made it clear that
there were things he could not go into
detail about because he and his team
might be suing twitch for giving him no
information as to why he was suddenly
banned
needless to say he will not be returning
to the platform and is setting his
sights on
doc 3.0 he's promising an epic return to
streaming while comparing the end goal
of doc 3.0
to be like its own mcu with cool
projects big surprises and new
cinematics to push the envelope
we've already seen that he's changed his
twitter url from his
twitch page to his youtube page but he
said he's not looking for any exclusive
streaming deals
at this time so even though we might
never know why he was banned there's
definitely more on the way from dr
disrespect
[Music]
starting in september in select
countries an xbox game pass ultimate
subscription is going to include
xcloud support project xcloud is another
avenue to
easy access for games letting you play
them without needing to download a file
at all
that means you'll be able to play the
game pass library on your phone or your
tablet with controller support
and online play through xbox live
servers
you'll even be able to pick up your
progress right where you left off
through the cloud saves
being able to play anywhere and
everywhere seems to be the expectation
for xbox
as spencer has even stated before that
customers view this world
of selling one piece of hardware that's
a closed ecosystem
as kind of a relic of the past it was
never explicitly stated that the xcloud
service was going to be solely for the
xbox series x
which means we might have more access to
games than we expected when it's
released this holiday season
so of course if you want to stay up to
date on all the xbox news then
stay locked on gamespot bungie announced
on its website that destiny 2 beyond
light
the game's next big expansion is getting
delayed it's now launching on november
10th across all platforms including ps4
xbox one and pc from a blog post bungie
said the past few months have been a
challenge and will continue to be during
this pandemic we've learned to create
together in a new way by having to work
apart from one another
despite these hurdles we're still
committed to the same level of quality
that our fans expect
additionally season of arrivals is being
extended until november 10th
since it was initially set to end on the
original beyond late launch date
with beyond light being the first of
three annual expansions that have
already been announced it's unclear
whether this delay
is going to affect the launch date of
witch queen and lightfall which are set
to come in the next few years
regardless of that though at least we
know there's a lot more on its way for
destiny too
you know what else is happening on
gamespot right now play for all
even though our play for all streams
have come to a close our donation drive
is staying open
from now until the end of august you can
visit store.gamesbot.com to snag some
merch and we'll be sending all of those
proceeds to support black lives matter
and covid19 relief efforts
we've already raised thousands and
thousands of dollars and we could not
have done
it without you guys thanks for watching
i'm persia and you can follow me on
twitter at persia underscore xo
make sure you stay safe this weekend so
we can see you
at your next safe state on monday with
kurt i'll see you guys later
peace out
you